Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Sag mal, hast du eigentlich eine Frage an den Staat.
Eine da müsste ich jetzt erst mal auf meiner Liste gucken, ob ich da eine von auswählen kann.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer vierhundertundfünfundzwanzig vom vierzehnten März zwanzig zweiundzwanzig. Yes, da sind wir wieder. Äh stimmt's Linus?
Wir sind das stimmt Tim. Du hast Recht. Ja.
Wir sind einfach wir sind. Wir sind, wir ruhen in uns und äh wir haben uns gedacht, ähm,
hat zuletzt ganz gut geklappt mit all den Gästen. Da machen wir auch gleich mal wieder weiter. Und äh wir machen heute mal so ein kleines Spezial äh Sendung zu ähm ja zu frag den Staat und wen sollte man da sonst einladen außer Anne? Hallo Anne.
Hallo, ich ruhe auch in mir.
Ist auch in dir. Das ist sehr wichtig. Äh gerade hier ist das sehr wichtig, ne. Arne Arne Senfroth, ähm genau. Wir hatten dich schon ein paar Mal äh da. Das hat bisher immer ganz gut funktioniert. Da sagt man kann wiederkommen.
Dankeschön. Ja äh auf der Bühne war ich mal mit euch. Das war sehr sehr schön. Bei der zweihundertsechsundfünfzig.
Diese da hast du auch direkt den Sendungsti äh geklärt. Was war das nochmal irgendwie? Ich ich muss gerade noch überlegen, was denn der äh was der Sendungstitel war. Wir haben ja letztes Mal schon überlegt ähm.
So und so viele Leute auf auf 1 ,3 Stellen, also.
Ja, zehn.tausend Leute auf 1,3 Stellen und das war die Beschreibung der äh mehr oder weniger der finanziellen Situation von frag den Staat.
Und wir machen heute eine Feelgood Sendung.
Weil man braucht ja gerade meine Sendung, wir machen ja immer so viel schlechte Nachrichten, deswegen möchten wir jetzt mal in diesen Zeiten etwas antizyklisch agieren,
und außerdem äh gibt's wirklich würde ich sagen gute Nachrichten bei euch, ne? Also fragt den Staat hat sich ja echt äh hätte man ja nicht gedacht, dass es euch noch was wird.
Hat sich nicht abgezeichnet.
Für uns übrigens auch nicht, aber das ist eben muss man auch sagen, das ist auch wirklich schön, dass ich für eine Feel-Good-Sendung eingeladen werde, während mein Bruder in der Regel für das Gegenteil eingeladen wird. Das ist eine ganz schöne familiäre Aufteilung, die wir bei uns.
Das hat er sich aber auch selber so ausgesucht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er sich das selber ausgesucht hat, aber ähm.
Na ja doch, hat schon ein bisschen das Thema gesetzt, finde ich.
Okay.
Ja also frag den Start, ne? Gib eine Menge zu erzielen.
Bevor wir bevor bevor wir darüber äh reden musste um äh natürlich noch ein noch ein Test bestehen und ähm.
Äh uns sagen, was der HTTP-Status quot vierhundert25 ist, weil wir haben ja die Sendung vierhundertfünfundzwanzig und da wollen wir auch über Statuscodes reden, weil das ist wirklich wichtig im Leben.
Scheiße, nee, weiß ich nicht.
Früh die Frage.
Ja, kam zu früh die Frage. Der HTP-Statuscode 425 heißt two early und äh äh hat äh gemeinhin damit zu tun, dass der Server unwillig ist.
Das kennen wir ja, diese unwilligen Server, ne und ähm,
Das ist eigentlich deine Gelegenheit nochmal was zu erklären, weil was damit ja unter anderem verhindert werden soll, sind so Replay-Attacken, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Server will irgendwelche Informationen noch nicht rausrücken, weil ist zu früh. Was was was was soll denn damit verhindert werden?
Also ein Replay-Angriff ähm bedeutet im weitesten Sinne, dass man jetzt vielleicht einen Teil einer Kommunikation aufzeichnet und wieder abspielen kann
und dadurch,
zum Beispiel wieder einen Zugriff erlangt, also ein Replay-Angriff um die zu verhindern, sorgt man eigentlich dafür, dass Antworten,
nicht. Ähm,
immer gleich sind. Also die einfachste Möglichkeit ist immer irgendwie eine Zufallszahl mit einmischen, um dann halt quasi zu verhindern, dass ähm,
quasi eine Antwort, die gestern richtig war, heute noch richtig ist, einfach weil man diese äh Zufallszahl wieder mit drin,
Das betrifft also so das gesamte Feld des Replay-Angriffs. Mir ist nur nicht ganz klar, wie ähm.
Dieser Status Cottersfelder so, ja.
Das in wie dieser Statuscode dem entgegentreten soll, ja? Insofern bin ich etwas ähm.
Verwundert, dass dass es das hier gibt. Der steht auch irgendwie nicht auf den üblichen beschrieben.
Gibt auf jeden Fall ein ausführliches FC, das können wir dazu noch äh verlinken, weil es irgendwie äh erklärt, wie man äh mit early Data in HTTP umzugehen hat, gefälligst. Und wenn's ist, dann gibt's halt Fehlermeldungen.
Also wenn's ja ich werde also der RFC vierundachtzig siebzig.
Ich wusste nicht, dass ich das dass ich jetzt die Sendung so damit die rede.
Machen sich Gedanken drüber, sei TLS eins Punkt drei, der ist von September zwanzig achtzehn. Okay, da müssen wir nochmal, da muss ich nochmal reinschauen, ehrlich gesagt. Ich ich lese den mal hier. Vielleicht äh.
Fällt dir zum Ende der Sendung noch was ein.
Na gut, dann kommen wir äh was?
Ah okay nee okay wenn ich das richtig verstehe wenn du direkt nachdem du überhaupt einen TLS-Kontext äh aufgebaut hast schon.
Den Request schickst, dann kannst du halt einfach sagen, du, das ist ein bisschen früh.
Warum ist es dann zu früh? Warum.
Vielleicht erwarten würdest, dass die Person vorher nochmal die Seite aufruft, wo sehr wo der Regress erstmal generiert wird oder.
Ach so, das war jetzt zu schnell sozusagen. Das das kommt mir verdächtig vor, heißt das also eigentlich. So ja, kannste, kannste schon schicken, aber aber jetzt nee. So musst du noch ein bisschen warten.
Also richtig bin ich nicht überzeugt.
Na ja.
Das wird in den Kommentaren geklärt, wie alles andere.
Denke ich allerdings auch. Na gut, dann,
Doch äh zu unserem eigentlichen äh Kernthema, nämlich frag den Staat Arne. Wir hatten äh schon ein paar Mal die äh Ehre miteinander und vor allem zuletzt haben wir beide uns äh unterhalten. Da war der Linus irgendwie weg.
Und zwar haben wir uns damals über das Projekt Volksentscheid Transparenzgesetz äh unterhalten, das jetzt wirklich fast drei Jahre her, 29. April 19. Da gab's noch keine Pandemie und all das.
Da haben wir noch haben wir noch positiv in die Zukunft geschaut,
Also ich mache das ja du nicht, aber ich mach's immer noch. Also okay, hat sich nichts geändert. Du hast nicht positiv in die Zukunft geschaut. Ich schon.
Ach nee, ist die Feelgood Sendung, sorry. Ähm nee, damals nicht, aber jetzt schon
denn es wird alles besser. Ähm damals hatten wir ein Transparenzgesetz geschrieben, also ein Gesetz, das den Staat, in dem Fall das Land Berlin verpflichten sollte, allen möglichen wichtigen Dokumenten von sich aus zu veröffentlichen. Das hatten wir in einem äh
Volksbegehren an den Senat herangetragen, hatten da 32.000 Unterschriften für gesammelt letztlich
und der Senat, der hat das dann erstmal anderthalb Jahre liegen lassen, hat dann,
Eigenen Entwurf gemacht, ist damit nicht durchgekommen. Da waren Neuwahlen und jetzt sind wir wieder auf null. Das ist so der Stand davon,
in Berlin hat jetzt die neue rot-rot-grüne Regierung versprochen Transparenzgesetz einzuführen so wie übrigens die Bundesregierung auch die Ampelkoalition auch,
ähm aber de facto hat sich weder auf Bundesebene noch auf Berliner Ebene gesetzlich bisher was getan, also viele Initiativen immer wieder, aber so richtig,
geändert ist da nichts, das heißt wir haben in Berlin immer noch das Gesetz, was wir vor über 20 Jahren hatten und auf Bundesebene auch.
Hm und was heißt das jetzt? Also was macht ihr da als nächstes.
Also grundsätzlich heißt das, dass man jetzt erstmal weiterhin die normalen Vasallenrechte hat. Man kann den Staat fragen und wenn man das tut, dann hat man das Recht, alle möglichen Infos vom Staat zu bekommen. Also ich kann fragen nach einem Vertrag, ich kann fragen nach,
Kommunikation mit einer Lobbyistin. Ich kann,
Fragen nach, allem Möglichen, was was weiß ich. Horst Seehofer oder so, so intern geschrieben hat in der Behörde. Ich kann das alles kriegen. Aber ich muss eben danach fragen und die Idee,
von einem Transparenzgesetz wäre, das ganz viele dieser Infos schon direkt veröffentlicht werden würden, ohne dass man sie erst noch anfragen muss. Ähm das heißt, das ist jetzt weiterhin erst mal,
schwierig ist, aber man kann rankommen ähm und politisch hat sich jetzt weder auf Berliner noch auf Bundesebene bisher was getan. Ähm wir sind so in der.
Bisschen skeptischen Grundhaltung, weil wir mit einer Gesetzesreform nicht unbedingt verbinden, dass alles besser wird,
das ist ja durchaus auch die Möglichkeit für die Verwaltung mit einem Gesetzentwurf zurückzuschlagen und zwar Transparenzgesetz raufzuschreiben, aber eigentlich das Gegenteil zu meinen. Und da sind wir grad sehr skeptisch, ob das eigentlich positiv umgesetzt wird, was da so versprochen wird.
Hm. Okay, also eine Aktion habt ihr jetzt auf jeden Fall erst mal noch nicht weiter geplant zu dem Thema.
Also das Problem bei dem Volksentscheid ist, der wurde ganz einfach ähm mit den Fristen ausgehebelt. Da hat der Berliner Senat so lange gewartet, dass wir dann nicht mehr rechtzeitig äh in die nächste Stufe gehen konnten und da dann 170.000 Unterschriften sammeln,
und damit haben wir uns quasi und dann kam noch die Pandemie dazu. Er macht äh ist auch nochmal schwerer irgendwie Unterschriften zu sammeln. Da steht grad nix an, was wir grad viel machen, ist tatsächlich,
den Verantwortlichen sprechen, also den den Fachpolitiker in der einzelnen Parteien ähm und wir werden auch,
nochmal zumindest auf Bundesebene in eigenen Gesetzentwurf ähm vorstellen. Also wenn wenn der Staat das halt nicht von sich aus macht, dann dann legen wir ein bisschen vor und dann hoffen wir, dass wir die Diskussion darüber dann erst mal ins holen.
Was ist denn von diesem konkurrierenden Gesetzentwurf äh zu halten? Also warum haben wir es denn überhaupt gemacht? Also eigentlich müsste also.
Hast einen eigenen,
Entwurf, also es gibt einen Volksentscheid, dann machen sie diese Prüfung, dann machen sie einen eigenen was ist denn was sind denn da die entscheidenden Unterschiede?
Na das Interessante bei bei ja Informationsfreiheitsgesetzen und Transparenzgesetzen ist, dass das,
Gesetze sind die erstmal so der Verwaltung und den Interessen entgegen laufen. Also in der Innenverwaltung und ist immer die Innenverwaltung, also auch auf Bundesebene das Innenministerium,
zuständig ist. Das hat natürlich kein Interesse daran, dass ganz viele interne Dokumente auf einmal online sind. Ähm.
Genau die Verwaltung sind dann aber zuständig dafür, einen Gesetzentwurf zu prüfen und möglicherweise einen eigenen zu machen und da kann man sich dann ja ausrechnen, was dabei rumkommt. Das ist,
so wie wenn die Banken sich selbst das Gesetz zur Bankenregulierung schreiben würden, ja was sie.
Ja genau und genauso ist es.
Also ist das Gleiche wie im Bankenwesen im Prinzip. Ähm bei der Informationsfreiheitsgesetzen auch. Also im Prinzip richtig wäre, wenn das Parlament ähm so einen Gesetzentwurf macht oder halt die Zivilgesellschaft und das dann vom Parlament verabschiedet.
Die Innenministerien erstmal so einen ersten Aufschlag machen, dann sind da in der Regel die kleinen Vießheiten schon alle drin und was man zum Beispiel in Berlin versucht hat mit dem eigenen Entwurf,
so eine Identifizierungspflicht einzuführen. Also das ist das, was das Innenministerium vielleicht mit einer E-Perso-Pflicht oder so versuchen würde,
hatten da dann reingeschrieben, dass man ähm halt Name und Adresse angeben muss bei bei einem Informationsantrag, dass dann diese Daten an Dritte weitergegeben werden dürfen in bestimmten,
Fällen, das heißt die haben schon direkt,
ähm ja die Informationsfreiheit in die andere Richtung interpretieren und haben sich gedacht, ja wir wollen dann erstmal ordentlich was darüber wissen, wer uns da eigentlich anfragt und dieses Grundprinzip alle können anfragen, müssen keine Begründung geben, damit dann schon mal ausgehebelt,
und gleichzeitig und das merkt man so in solchen,
Gesetzgebungsverfahren. Da werden dann alle möglichen anderen Ressorts gefragt. Die anderen Senatsverwaltungen, die anderen Ministerien, ja was haltet ihr denn davon? Und dann sagen die finden wir super, finden wir super, aber bei uns,
sollte dieser Bereich auch noch ausgenommen werden. Also so ein so ein klassisches Nimbi, ne,
Transparenz finden alle immer toll, aber wenn's dann um sie selbst geht, dann gibt's gute Gründe dafür, warum jetzt dieser eine Teil jetzt auch noch eine extra Ausnahme kriegen sollte und.
Dementsprechend war das dann auch ein ziemlicher Fleckenteppich, wo dann letztlich für jeden Bereich, also die die Bildungsverwaltung in Berlin wollte dann die Schulen einmal komplett ausnehmen zum Beispiel, damit nicht rauskommt, was die da für eine Miss.
Die Justizverwaltung wird dann die Stiftungsaufsicht rausnehmen und so weiter und so weiter. Ähm das war dann ein so schlechter Entwurf, da muss man sagen, ja ist eigentlich ganz gut, dass letztlich nix aus irgendwas geworden ist. Das wäre nur noch schlimmer geworden als es jetzt.
Tja.
Sehr schön. Äh.
Aber was ist denn so in eurem Kern äh Geschäft passiert? Ihr seid ja eigentlich ähm dazu da ähm,
Staat zu befragen, wie hat sich denn so dieses Befragewesen so äh entwickelt, so rein quantitativ vielleicht zunächst einmal äh äh oder auch qualitativ.
Ja, also bei Folge 2hundertsechsundfünfzig waren wir ja bei zehntausend Personen, glaube ich,
die Anfragen gestellt hatten und wir hatten 1,3 Stellen, weil fragt den Staat, die das irgendwie versucht haben zu managen. Jetzt sind wir bei 100.000 Personen auf 15 Stellen. Also beides hat sich ungefähr verzehnfacht. Ähm überfragt den Staat sind jetzt,
in den letzten zehn Jahren insgesamt hundert ja genau 100tausend Leute haben über 200.000 Anfragen gestellt ähm und das,
zeigt so glaube ich schon ganz gut, was sich entwickelt hat, dass es nämlich immer normaler wird, überhaupt den Staat zu fragen. Also wenn wir uns so ein bisschen die Anfangszeit,
Dieses Projekt fragt den Staat anschauen, da war das ja sehr lange ziemliche Nische, ne? Also ich glaube, so die.
So Leute ausm CCC Umfeld haben von Anfang an. Viel fragt den Staat genutzt und dann Dokumente befreit und es gab ja auch ein Vorgängerprojekt beim CCC, befreite Dokumente. Ähm da war das schon lange bekannt, aber.
Diese Nische dann ein bisschen zu erweitern und dann auch,
Leute aus anderen zivilgesellschaftlichen Bereichen für diese Möglichkeiten zu begeistern, mehr Journalistinnen, mehr einfach Privatpersonen dazu zu kriegen wirklich anzufragen. Das ist uns, glaube ich, inzwischen ganz gut gelungen.
Ähm und das führt dazu, dass.
Informationsfreiheit auch in die Breite geht. Das ist also im Prinzip in jeder Kommune in Deutschland inzwischen,
ein paar Leute gibt, die was anfragen und dementsprechend sich die Verwaltung damit beschäftigen muss. Also es kommt niemand mehr drum herum, so ähm.
Und das hat dann glaube ich gegenteilige Auswirkungen. Das kann zum einen dazu führen, dass,
ist tatsächlich auch so eine neue Generation gibt in der Verwaltung, ein paar jüngere Leute, die für die Transparenz ein bisschen normaler ist und die dann vielleicht auch,
lieber mal was rausgeben und das führt aber andererseits natürlich auch dazu, dass.
Der Hass auch fragt den Staat teilweise noch noch stärker geworden ist und und so die Versuche dann Informationsfreiheit zu umgehen noch stärker geworden.
Mhm. Also Abwehrstrategien, die äh hochgeholt werden, so wie du es eben auch schon beschrieben hast, so ein bisschen mit so ja was ihr wollt was rauskriegen, das wären wir schon zu verhindern wissen, ne?
Genau, also in der Praxis ähm war das ja gab's ja so ein paar Geschichten von zum Beispiel Andreas Scheuer dem Ex Verkehrsminister, der dann ganz viel seiner.
Komischen Deals nur noch per WhatsApp-Nachricht ähm gemacht hat, was dazu geführt hat, dass die offiziell nicht mehr in den Akten waren und man sie nicht mehr anfragen konnte.
Ähm und solche Bewegungen, die haben wir ja grundsätzlich durchaus einige, das dann eher so über private Kommunikationsmittel versucht wird, Transparenzpflichten zu umgehen.
Und wir haben dann und das ist dann so ein bisschen fragt den Start spezifischer, durchaus auch Behörden, die ihre eigenen Plattformen,
Also ähm in Deutschland das Statistische Bundesamt hat sich so ein eigenes, fraglin Staat gebaut, äh Frontex, die EU-Grenzpolizei hat sich so ein eigenes Fragmentstaat gebaut,
und die EU-Kommission baut grad dran und das Innenministerium schaut sich das auch an und was natürlich das Ziel von den ganzen Dingern ist,
ähm ist dann letztlich so ein so ein Anfrageverkehr letztlich über die die Plattform des Staates zu laufen äh laufen zu lassen.
Wo dann die Kommunikation aber nicht mehr öffentlich einsehbar ist für alle, wo dann nicht mehr nachvollzogen werden kann, was da eigentlich rausgegeben wird und nicht. Und da wird jetzt grad im Innenministerium, wie wir's mitbekommen, schon einige Zeit investiert, um sich anzuschauen, wie so was aussehen kann.
Beruhigt dich das eher oder findest du es eher beunruhigend? Also ich meine, man könnte auf der einen Seite sagen, ja, schön, der Staat sorgt selber dafür, dass jetzt hier sozusagen Anfragen auch gestellt werden können. Ne?
Na ja, wir haben so ein bisschen das Problem, dass wir, glaube ich, in ganz vielen dieser IT-Projekten gibt, dass es aus der Zivilgesellschaft schon funktionierendes Projekt gibt und anstatt halt mit den Leuten zu reden und zu schauen, wie können wir denn eben.
Ja? Davon lernen oder wie kann man vielleicht auch die finanzieren für ein paar Sachen, also wir würden jetzt kein Geld annehmen vom Innenministerium, aber,
trotzdem irgendwie austauschen, würden wir uns ja schon. Anstatt so was zu machen, gibt man dann lieber was in Auftrag und na ja, man kann sich ja irgendwie denken, was dann am Schluss,
rauskommen würde, wenn so was extern vergeben würde. Ähm und dann hörten die noch das Föderalismusproblem dazu, also bei uns kann man alle Behörden anfragen, wahrscheinlich,
Bundesprojekt nur die Bundesbehörden. Das wird dann auch schon schwieriger. Also,
ich ich kann das leider nicht als irgendwie eine Wertschätzung sehen, auch wenn ich das gern machen würde, aber wir haben ähm auf unserer Startseite immer noch so das Lieblingszitat vom Innenministerium,
als Auszeichnung stehen. Das das war so ein Zitat von einem Beamten des Innenministeriums aus einer Gerichtsverhandlung. Da hat er nämlich gesagt,
durch Portale, wie frag den Staat gelangen immer mehr Dinge an die Öffentlichkeit, das ist eine Entwicklung, die für die Verwaltung nicht wünschenswert ist,
ist so das das Haupttestimonial auf unserer Start.
Hm. Ist es denn eigentlich in irgendeiner Form ähm,
klären wir uns doch nochmal kurz auf, was ist denn so der letzte Schritt? Also wenn man jetzt so eine Anfrage stellt, wie erreicht die denn dann die jeweilige Behörde und gibt's eigentlich irgendwie Behörden, die da nochmal spezieller angebunden sind und kürzere Wege bieten?
Ja also fragt den Staat, ist im Kern eigentlich,
seit Anfang an eine große Behördendatenbank mit äh Behördenadressen von 40.000 Behörden in Deutschland und auf EU-Ebene inzwischen auch ähm und fragt den Staat verschickt E-Mails.
Das heißt, wir haben so vorgefertigte Formulare, man wählt sich dann zum Beispiel das Innenministerium bei uns aus der Datenbank aus, sagte in einem Satz, ich will das den Vertrag, ich will die E-Mail haben,
schickt das ab und fragt den Staat, schickt das dann per E-Mail an das zuständiger Referat in der jeweiligen Behörde,
die Antworten idealerweise nach einem Monat darauf und die Antwort geht dann an die spezielle E-Mail-Adresse bei Fragten staat, die dafür sorgt,
die Antwort auch mit veröffentlicht wird auf der Anfrageseite,
so dass wir dann 200.000 verschiedene Anfrageseiten haben bei Frank und Staat, wo halt die Anfragen einsehbar sind und die Antworten darauf auch, die werden dann also befreit für alle.
Okay.
Jetzt hatten wir neulich äh Lilit äh Wittmann hier auch zu äh Gast, die so ihre ihren privaten Geheimdienst, den sie jetzt eröffnet hat, gesprochen haben, dem sie ja äh
der gesamten Behördenstruktur äh hinterher forscht. Da hatte der schon anklingen äh lassen, dass ihr da auch zusammenarbeitet. Was äh was wird denn dabei bei rauskommen?
Hm ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel ich davon erzählen darf. Ähm was hat sie denn gesagt, wie viel ich erzählen darf.
Im dass ihr in Kontakt seid.
Also ich ich glaube was.
Theoretisch ja eine Plattform des Staates machen könnte, wenn sie wollte. Wäre wirklich für ganz viel Transparenz darüber ähm.
Sorgen wer gerade innerhalb einer Behörde zuständig ist für was?
Und wer gerade was bearbeitet und wann etwas abgeschlossen ist. Also wenn jetzt nicht, frag den Staat einfach nur E-Mails verschicken würde, sondern mit einer,
Schnittstelle irgendwie verbunden wäre mit einem Verwaltungssystem von der Behörde. Dann könnte man natürlich da mit einbauen, dass man quasi live der Anfrage nachfolgen kann und dann nachschauen kann,
in welchem Referat wird das denn intern jetzt beantwortet? Ähm da sind wir nicht, weil die Behörden das nicht wollen, aber,
so die Frage, welches Referat ist denn für was zuständig? Glaube ich, ist so eine ganz,
zentrale und wichtige, die eine Behörde sehr ungern rausgibt und ich glaube, dass man dafür,
sehr viel mehr interessante Transparenz sorgen kann genau nachvollziehen zu können, wer ist denn jetzt eigentlich genau zuständig? Also klar am Kopf so einer Behörde ist dann Horst Seehofer dann Olaf Scholz aber,
Beamtenapparat mit 1tausend Leuten dahinter, der natürlich sehr viel mehr entscheidet und der ganz viele Grundlagen legt,
der sollte ein bisschen transparenter auch gegenüber der Öffentlichkeit machen, zu welchen Themen jetzt welche Person tatsächlich,
arbeitet und um diesen Bereich geht's. Habe ich das wage und abstrakt genug gemacht. Äh Lillit, schreib's in die Kommentare.
Aber äh zu deiner Information gibt keine Behörde mehr, der jetzt äh Horst Seehofer noch vorsteht. Also.
Das glaubst du. Ich bin mir ich bin mir noch nicht sicher.
Findet man ja immer wieder nochmal so kleine Behördchen.
Bestimmt noch eine aus.
Der Geist von Horst Seehofer, der ist auf jeden Fall.
Ja, allerdings. Das stimmt, der Geist äh von ja, der bleibt noch.
Jetzt ähm seid ihr ja auch fleißig äh am am Klagen aus, frag den Staat, wo du irgendwann verklagst äh den Staat. Weil.
Kriegt ja nicht unbedingt immer das, was man man will und um dann den Start dazu zu bekommen, dann doch noch mal rauszurücken, was man eigentlich haben wollte. Seid ihr ja dann in so eine Klagestrategie auch äh übergegangen. Wann fing das eigentlich an? Wie lange ist das jetzt her?
Ist wirklich glaube ich ernsthaft vier Jahre her. Also wir haben das tatsächlich gelauncht zu einem Chaos-Kongress. Das müsste der Becher war der letzte in Hamburg.
Zweiunddreißig.
Äh 33 war glaube ich sogar auch noch in Hamburg.
Dreiunddreißig C drei, ja.
Äh dann war das da. Ähm seitdem ähm äh das ging aber am Anfang nicht so wahnsinnig stark los, weil wir das immer noch mit dem selben Team gemacht hatten und wir nun alle,
keine Juristen sind oder gewesen sind, sondern nur die Horst Seehofer sich selbst genannt hat, eine Erfahrungsjuristen. Ähm,
wir haben dann ähm aber tatsächlich vor.
Zwei Jahren ähm den ersten Juristen bei uns im Team gehabt und inzwischen haben wir ein größeres äh Team von Juristin bei uns direkt mit drin. Ähm und wir sind inzwischen in der Lage im Prinzip,
innerhalb von äh zwei, drei Tagen, wenn wir wollen, eine Klage aufzusetzen und das das verändert so ein ganzes Spiel natürlich und wir sind inzwischen bei knapp 120 Klagen,
die wir eingereicht haben und die Hälfte davon ist jetzt schon durch und wir arbeiten auch grad an einem,
Untätigkeitsklagengenerator. Also daran tatsächlich so ein bisschen Ligal-Tech-mäßig, das treibt den Staat einem, wenn man ähm nicht rechtzeitig eine Antwort bekommt, dann eine Klage vorformuliert automatisch und die kümmern sich dann,
ausdrucken oder wir haben auch mit Faxfunktion tatsächlich, wir gehen mit der Zeit ähm man kann auch die per Fax dann die Klage idealerweise beim beim Verwaltungsbericht direkt einreichen.
Er hat die die Grundidee des Ganzen ist, dass wir.
Irgendwann erkannt haben, dass zwar mehr Leute anfragen, aber das nicht unbedingt dazu führt, dass man mehr Infos bekommt und wenn man da so einen gewissen Credibal Fred aufbauen kann und zeigen kann,
ja? Immer dann, wenn hier wirklich grotesk irgendwie was nicht rausgegeben wird, was rausgegeben werden müsste,
Klagenbehalt und wir unterstützen auch Userinnen von Frag den Staat, wie wir's nicht kriegen und klagen,
dann verändert das so ein Spiel noch mal ein bisschen, weil dann natürlich die möglichen Kosten für die Gegenseite deutlich höher sind.
Sollte bei der Gelegenheit vielleicht nur mal kurz in Erinnerung rufen, euch geht's ja mit allem Engagement, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, final um die Selbstabschaffung, ne? Also ihr möchtet ja nicht mehr,
fragen müssen. Das also das scheint mir immer so, dass
Ziel eurer Aktion zu sein oder der der Grundgedanke eurer Aktion. Nicht, dass jetzt hier Hörerinnen denken, äh geil, Eddie machen eine die verklagen den Staat, da muss ich noch mehr Steuern zahlen. Das ist ja nicht wirklich das Ziel, was ihr verfolgt damit.
Nee, nee, tatsächlich nicht. Ähm also es es geht es geht natürlich schon. Also ich ich glaube nicht, also es gibt,
Teile von Fakten, Staat, da fände ich's total super, wenn die abgeschafft werden, weil weil's die nicht mehr braucht. Also,
wenn viele Informationen nicht mehr angefragt werden müssten, weil sie schon online vorhanden sind, dann wäre das total gut. Ich glaube aber, dass es tatsächlich trotzdem innerhalb dieses Systems.
Ähm zur Organisation wie frag den Staat und und Verwandteorganisation braucht als Gegengewicht, so als als kritische Gegengewichte, die dann halt ähm.
Bei bei bestimmten Sachen mehr nachfragen und dann auch klagen und ich glaube nicht, dass,
gut wäre, den Teil abzuschaffen sozusagen. Also den können wir gerne behalten, aber wenn wir uns mehr darauf ähm konzentrieren könnten ähm und so,
paar blöde Sachen, die wir auch immer mitschleifen, einfach weil der Staat sie nicht auf die Reihe kriegt, wenn man das nicht mehr machen müssen, dann wäre das.
Das ist äh äh natürlich sehr viel besser erklärt. Also so passte so passt halt die Idee eines Transparenzgesetzes. Also ihr sagt quasi ihr wollt ein Transparenzgesetz haben, damit ihr
kleinen gar nicht mehr anfragen müsst und euch auf die großen Fische konzentrieren könnt.
Genau. Genau, also ich ich glaube selbst wenn's ein Transparenzgesetz gibt, wird ein Innenministerium immer noch nicht alles von sich aus rausgeben. Da wird man immer noch hinterherhaken müssen. Ähm aber genau. Das dann ordentlich machen zu können, das wäre glaube.
Was für eine,
hundertzwanzig Klagen habt ihr bisher aufgemacht, 60 davon sind zu haben die jetzt alle so den selben Charakter jetzt eigentlich immer um ihr wolltet uns die Information nicht geben. Wir äh hauen drauf oder,
Variiert es noch.
Das ja das variiert ziemlich. Also das sind zum einen manchmal.
Eher kleine Klagen, dann auch teilweise eher in den Kommunen, die dann idealerweise sehr schnell einen Erziehungseffekt haben, also ähm eine Stadtverwaltung, die.
Mit einer absurden Argumentation dann ein kleines Dokument nicht rausgeben will. Da hilft dann eine Klage sehr häufig,
sehr gut dabei, dass dann die Stadtverwaltung sich mehr mit dem Recht auseinandersetzt und in Zukunft das besser macht. Das machen wir. Dann gibt es,
die größeren strategischen Fälle, also wir hatten das Innenministerium zum Beispiel verklagt auf Zugang zu deren Twitter, Direktnachrichten, weil wir vermutet hatten, dass der.
Twitter-Account vom Innenministerium, Innen-Twitter-Direkt-Nachrichten, Verwaltungsarbeit macht, also da dann bestimmte Abstimmungen macht, die eigentlich in der Akte sein sollten,
und dann über diese Twitter direkt Nachrichten ähm so die Transparenzpflichten umgeht. Das haben wir so als strategischen Fall angelegt von Anfang an,
haben damit dann gewonnen vom Verwaltungsgericht, haben verloren vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht und haben jetzt Verfassungsbeschwerde eingereicht dagegen,
Das ist so ein größerer Fall, wo es dann grundsätzlich darum geht,
muss nur was rausgegeben werden, was in einer Akte ist, wirklich. Oder es ist egal, wo es ist, Hauptsache es ist eine staatliche Info und wenn die jetzt bei Twitter ist oder bei WhatsApp oder so, ist egal, muss trotzdem rausgegeben werden. Das wäre so ein größerer Fall.
Und dann haben wir immer wieder aktuelle Fälle, die jetzt einfach gerade,
wichtig sind. Also jetzt diese Tage hoffentlich noch morgen, übermorgen irgendwie so ähm geht eine Klage raus gegen das Bundeskanzleramt, wo es um die ähm,
die den Terminkalender von Gerhard Schröder geht äh in den letzten Jahren. Gerhard Schröder, der ähm,
Ist ja eben nicht privat man, sondern ist tatsächlich als Bundeskanzler außer Dienst,
weiterhin jemand, der Steuergelder bekommt, der ein eigenes Büro hat ähm von Steuergeldern finanziert, die seine repräsentativen Ausgaben äh äh seine repräsentativen Aufgaben, Aufgaben ähm.
Regeln sollen und dieses repräsentative Büro hat nun aber Lobby-Termine gemacht für Schröder. Und äh wir wollten diesen Terminkalender haben, haben den nicht bekommen ähm und klagen jetzt in so einem Eilverfahren.
Ähm und das ist ein ganz spannendes Verfahren, weil noch nie jemand zu einem Kanzler, außer Dienst irgendwie äh geklagt hat,
und auch sehr praktisch ist das ein sehr interessantes Verfahren, weil das gesamte Büro von Schröder gekündigt hat vor kurzem und deswegen gar nicht klar ist, wer uns denn eigentlich die Anfrage beantworten.
Müsste dann notfalls halt Schröder selbst machen. Ähm das sind dann also die schnellen Klagen. Das heißt so die kleinen, die großen und die schnellen Klagen, das ist eigentlich was wir versuchen.
Habt ihr da so ein Warroom, wo ihr euch irgendwie die ganze Zeit das so äh ausdenkt, wo jetzt die nächste Attacke äh gefahren wird? Da ist es ja ganz schön umfangreich.
Es ist wirklich umfangreich. Ähm,
es ist aber irgendwie so, dass es sich organisch ergibt, habe ich den Eindruck. Also ähm natürlich gibt's die Impulse von frag den Staat Userinnen, die auf uns zukommen und sagen, hier, ich würde hier gern,
Klagen, ähm dann ist es auch einfach ganz viel Frustration, also wenn's eine Art gibt, wie wir immer wieder,
vor die Wand laufen und dann denken wir uns halt da müssen wir jetzt was machen und jetzt mit Schröder muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, das ist so auch mein Weg mit,
Ohnmacht umzugehen. Also ich will gerne irgendwie was machen, ich will irgendwie was Sinnvolles tun. Ähm.
Ja Schröder ärgert mich, also schaue ich, was können wir machen ähm und ja Schröder verklagen scheint dann eine ganz guter Weg zu sein.
Schröder ärgert dich.
Und wie muss man sich das so vorstellen? Wie wie wie habt ihr euch da aufgestellt? Du hast jetzt gesagt, 15 Leute seid ihr ähm in was für einem Gremium und welcher Art.
Beschließt ihr solche Sachen, solche solche Klagen auch zu machen?
Ja, also fragt den Staat ist ähm ein Teil der Open Knowledge Foundation, gemeinnütziger Trägerverein äh von frag den Staat,
ist aber bei solchen Entscheidungen eigentlich ziemlich autonom. Ähm wir haben verschiedene Teams innerhalb dieser fünfzehn Leute. Also wir haben das so aufgeteilt nach,
dem Tech-Team, ähm drei Leute, die sich halt um die Plattform an sich kümmern und neue Features und so weiter,
ähm Stefan Wehrmeier ist dabei, ähm der,
gegründet und entwickelt hat. Dann haben wir ähm dieses Team mit den Juristinnen. Wir haben äh Leute für Kampagne und wir haben äh das Recherche-Team und dann noch Leute, die dazu Community-Entwicklung machen, Fundraising und so was,
und die Entscheidung die treffen wir zum einen im Gesamtteam, wir haben jetzt grad noch so eine Größe in der man das kann, wenn wir noch größer werden würden, dann würde es auf jeden Fall strukturell ein bisschen schwieriger werden, denke ich,
und wir haben dann die kleinen Teams und dann.
Sozusagen darum wie schwerwiegend und möglicherweise kontrovers ist eine Entscheidung, die.
Leichter und weniger kontrovers sie ist, desto weniger Leute werden beteiligt und wenn's dann aber wirklich um um was Großes, Kontroverses geht, dann ist es das Gesamtteam dazu.
Mhm. Jetzt fahrt ihr ja auch ähm Kampagnen.
Ähm unter anderem zum Urheberrecht, ähm weiß gar nicht, wie viele Kampagnen habt ihr so am Start?
Lobbyregister, Blackbox, oh Gott, ist ja auch drei, vier, fünf, sechs mein Gott, was was macht ihr den ganzen Tag? Also echt wirklich wer will denn so viel arbeiten?
Na ja, ist Pandemie, was willst du machen? Irgendwas muss man ja mal.
Okay, definiere mal was was für euch eine Kampagne äh ist.
Also so eine klassische frag den Startkampagne ist letztlich eigentlich eine eine Massenanfragenkampagne. Also wir,
versuchen und das immer zusammen mit anderen ähm zivilgesellschaftlichen Organisationen zusammen und so ein Themenbereich rauszusuchen, in dem.
Viele Anfragen von vielen Leuten dazu führen, dass Infos von sich aus veröffentlicht werden. So einer, an der man das, glaube ich, ganz gut.
Festmachen kann ist topsecret eine Kampagne die wir mit mit Foodwatch seid inzwischen drei Jahren machen,
wo es darum geht, Hygienekontrollberichte von den Lebensmittelaufsichtsbehörden anzufragen. Ähm heißt ganz konkret, ich will wissen, das Restaurant um die Ecke, da äh,
immer ein bisschen komisch. Ich will wissen, ist es da eigentlich sauber? Dann kann ich über top secret über so eine Kartenanwendung wie dieses Restaurant aussuchen, ähm kann dann,
Automatisiert äh eine Anfrage stellen an die zuständige Aufsichtsbehörde und die müssen wir dann die Kontrollberichte schicken,
das ist eine Kampagne, die letztlich dazu führen soll, dass Kontrollberichte vom Staat von sich aus veröffentlicht werden, wie das in vielen anderen Ländern der Fall ist,
ähm und das ist eine Kampagne, die,
wahnsinnig viele Leute interessiert, hätte ich vorher nicht gedacht. Ist nicht so mein Thema, aber da sind knapp 50.000 Anfragen über diese Kampagne schon gegangen in ganz Deutschland,
was zum Beispiel dazu geführt hat, dass in Berlin jetzt ab nächstem Jahr äh so ein Gesetz gibt, wo diese Berichte und die Ergebnisse davon an den Ladentüren ausgehängt werden müssen,
und was letztlich dazu führt, dass es dann topsecret dort nicht mehr braucht. Das ist so eine, so eine klassische Art,
solche Kampagnen machen. Das haben wir mit wissenschaftlichen Dienstgutachten beim Bundestag gemacht. Das haben wir mit ähm.
Mit so Gesetzgebungsentwürfen, äh Gesetzentwürfen von von äh Bundesministerien gemacht, die jetzt jeweils alle öffentlich sind,
und das,
ja? Äh führt dazu, dass er auf jeden Fall mehr Anfragen gibt, aber bei vielen dieser dieser Kampagnen auch dazu, dass dass der Staat das idealerweise dann von von sich aus macht und muss nicht mehr.
Mhm.
Kann ich schon verstehen, dass das dass das sozusagen auf Interesse äh stößt, ne. Viele andere Sachen sind ja sehr ich sage mal ein bisschen so verkopft juristisch politisch, ne.
So Urheberrecht und so weiter, versteht immer keiner. So aber irgendwie ist der Laden sauber, wo ich jetzt gleich essen will. Das hat einfach mal,
Bezug so ne.
Das stimmt total, ja und und unsere Hoffnung dabei ist, dass wir Leute über,
so eine Anfrage, die ist dann auch vorformuliert. Da muss man sich dann nicht mehr viel irgendwie mit den Juristereien auskennen. Darüber reinkommen in dieses Business und sich dann denken, ah okay, wenn ich an den Bericht reinkommen kann,
Was kann ich denn als nächstes anfragen? So und einfach nur die leere Seite und frag mal irgendwas an. Das funktioniert halt nicht so einfach wie,
wie so eine direkte Selbstwirksamkeitserfahrung, oh wow, ich kann dir was vom vom Staat kriegen und der Staat ist ja nicht nur,
Polizei und Finanzamt, wenn die mir was zuschicken, sondern vielleicht müssen die mir auch Infos zuschicken und über diese Erfahrung generieren wir so was hoffentlich. Das ist zumindest so so die ursprüngliche Idee dieser Kampagne.
Okay, ähm also ich gehe jetzt sozusagen auch voll voll Populismus jetzt.
Voll. Also ich meine, das das Gesetz da, das Gesetz äh haben nicht wir beschlossen, sondern das hat der Bundestag beschlossen, jetzt muss das genutzt werden und dafür sorgen wir und das ist äh dann der Populismus im besten Sinne.
Okay hm was sind denn so die Kampagnen, die dir besonders am Herzen liegen?
Also eine, die tatsächlich jahrelange ähm.
Auch Rechtsstreit nach sich gezogen hat. Das war eine, in der es ums Urheberrecht oder wir sagen dann Zensurheberrecht. Geht, das war ähm eine Kampagne, die auch,
großen Massenanfragenanteil hatte. Da ging's um das Bundesinstitut für Risikobewertung. Das ist ein staatliches Institut,
von dem wir vor,
Ich glaube inzwischen auch drei Jahren ähm vor der Pandemie auf jeden Fall ähm ein Gutachten angefragt hatten zu äh Glyphosat, also dem,
Pflanzenschutzmittel das möglicherweise krebserregend ist und wir hatten dann ein internes Kurzgutachten zu angefragt zur Frage, ob es denn krebserregend ist,
Auch bekommen und haben's dann veröffentlicht und dann hat das äh Bundesinstitut dann hat letztlich also die Bundesregierung indirekt,
uns dafür abgemahnt und letztlich auch verklagt wegen Urheberrechtsverletzungen. Wir haben also gesagt, diese staatlich finanzierte von Beamten geschriebene Gutachten, dass ähm dürft ihr zwar haben nach dem Gesetz, aber veröffentlichen dürft ihr das nicht, weil wir das Urheber.
Und das war erstmal juristisch eine sehr interessante Sache. Also darauf muss man ja erstmal kommen, dass der Staat tatsächlich ein Urheberrecht hat auf sowas. Ähm was von uns allen bezahlt ist,
Das ist aber was, da sind wir tatsächlich in der ersten Instanz beim Landgericht im einsweiligen Verfahren ähm erstmal auf die Nase gefallen. Das hat nämlich gesagt, wir sollen dieses Gutachten runternehmen. Ne, Staat hat einen Urheberrecht, haben die gesagt.
Haben wir uns gedacht, okay, wenn wir das aber angefragt haben und das veröffentlichen vielleicht nicht ging, aber das Anfragen schon, dann kann ja jede Person was anfragen,
haben da so ein kleines Tool gebaut, über das man das so mit anfragen konnte und das haben 45.000 Leute gemacht innerhalb von zwei Tagen.
Und das hat dazu geführt, dass letztlich 45.000 Leute dieses Gutachten privat bekommen haben. Veröffentlichen durfte man's nicht, aber ähm 45.000 Leute hatten das dann,
Das hat dann wiederum ähm vor Gerichten sehr interessanten Impuls gegeben, weil wir dann vor Gericht argumentieren konnten. Dieses Gutachten ist ja quasi schon veröffentlicht. Wenn 45.000 Leute das haben,
Da haben wir's ja viel mehr gelesen, als wenn man's auf die Website getan hätte. Und das war eine Argumentation, die hat vor Gericht auch gezogen und wir sind jetzt über die über die Jahre ähm,
Landgericht bevor es,
Oberlandesgericht und jetzt noch vorm äh Bundesgerichtshof BGH gekommen, ähm weil das Bundesinstitut das nicht akzeptieren wollte. Die haben da über 200.000 Euro für Anwälte ausgegeben, ähm haben aber in jeder Instanz verloren. Ähm und äh.
Bald verkünden wir das auch, verdammt. Das ist noch gar keine News, ne? Okay, ihr habt's zuerst gehört bei Logbuch.
Yeah.
Haben auch vorm Bundesgerichtshof äh gewonnen. Das heißt dieser dieser äh Fall ist jetzt durch und ähm.
Lässt sich dadurch, dass so viele Leute mitgemacht haben und sich dann eben ähm getraut haben so eine erste Anfrage zu machen ähm,
dadurch ja, haben wir tatsächlich glaube ich dieses Urheberrechtsthema so ein bisschen äh in Richtung Informationsfreiheit verschoben.
Ja schön, schön ist es auch. Äh dokumentiert. Das gefällt mir immer wieder äh sehr gut bei euch. Ihr habt irgendwie da wirklich eine eine klare äh Webseite, die Sachen ordentlich dokumentiert, so jetzt bei den Kampagnen, worum geht's? Dann die ganzen
dokumente im Original direkt so in der Webseite äh mit drin, fragen einfach äh erklärt.
Vor allem dann noch so eine klare Timeline, wo man irgendwie schnell nachvollziehen kann was Sache ist und sich's noch Sonstige äh Dokumente runterladen kann. Also das
Das funktioniert ganz gut.
Das ist gut. Von Nerds für Nerds. Wir sind grad in so einer Rede designt Diskussion intern. Ich äh nehme dieses Feedback sehr gerne mit. Es funktioniert doch alles, Leute.
Ja. Äh dem Hohenzollernprinz wollt ihr auch noch irgendwie.
Ja äh den Prinzenfond, den haben wir gegründet vor.
Vor der Pandemie, oh Gott, ich sage das so oft, ne, äh vor zwei Jahren oder so. Ähm das war eine Reaktion darauf, dass ähm Herr Prinz von Preußen, Georg Friedrich Prinz von Preußen, der der Thronfolger,
ähm in der Debatte um mögliche Entschädigungsforderungen und äh auch die Frage der,
der äh Rolle der Hohenzollern während der Nazizeit ähm angefangen hatte ganz viele Journalistinnen und äh Wissenschaftlerinnen ähm abzumahnen und zu verklagen für Äußerungen. Der hat.
Viele viele Dutzend, wahrscheinlich über 1hundert Leute ähm abgemahnt ähm und hat dazu letztlich,
Ganz viel beigetragen, dass viele sich nicht mehr getraut haben, sich öffentlich zu äußern. Ähm was,
was ein Wahnsinnseingriff letztlich dann war in in so eine freie Debatte, weil ganz viele Wissenschaftlerinnen, die dazu eigentlich geforscht hatten, sich nicht mehr getraut haben, dann öffentlich was dazu zu sagen. Und wir haben in Reaktion da auch den Prinzenfond gegründet,
der letztlichen Rechtsschutzfond ist für Betroffene und wir haben dann aus diesem Prinzenfond ähm Journalistin und WissenschaftlerInnen finanziert und beraten und Anwälte gestellt, damit die dann in solchen Verfahren,
nicht direkt eine Unterlassenserklärung unterschreiben müssen, einfach aus finanziellen Druck, sondern ganz entspannt vor Gericht gehen können und dann das da ausfechten können, was dann auch viele gemacht haben und was letztlich,
Das hat sich so grad in den letzten Monaten gezeigt, dazu geführt hat, dass der Prinz eigentlich ähm in den meisten Fällen verloren hat und ähm.
Wir zumindest auch kein neuer Fall mehr bekannt ist, wo irgendwie so eine Abmahnung jetzt passieren würde, weil der ganz schön äh auf die Krone bekommen hat. Äh vorm vorm Kammergericht und vor vorm Landgericht,
ähm.
Glaube ich auch die die Öffentlichkeit ganz gut mitbekommen hat, dass jemand, der äh Wissenschaftler die ganze Zeit verklagt, vielleicht nicht eine Person ist, die jetzt irgendwie noch Entschädigungszahlungen kriegt.
Jetzt auf die Krone gekriegt. Oh Mann.
Ich ich habe ja nicht so eine Begeisterung für Monarchinnen und Monarchen. Ähm aber ist schon sehr.
Schon echt spannend, was sich da für eine für eine Welt auftut, ne? Was ist das für ein für ein Vöglein? Das ist ja ein total lustiger Typ.
Na ja und also das Interessante daran finde ich eigentlich, dass man, wenn man nur genug Geld hat, um Anwälte zu bezahlen, auch tatsächlich so eine Drohkulisse ähm.
Aufbauen kann. Also dazu muss man noch nicht mal unbedingt im Recht sein, aber einfach wenn man jemand mit ordentlich aggressiver Sprache vor,
schickt der dann alle Leute einschüchtert und dann direkt eine Rechnung mitschickt, dann kann man schon ganz viel dafür sorgen, dass Leute das ganz eingeschüchtert unterschreiben,
ähm und das ist natürlich eine ganz ganz große Gefahr für die Informationsfreiheit und das ist quasi Informationsfreiheit ein bisschen weiter gedacht, eben nicht nur,
Wir fragen was an und sollen das bekommen, sondern wenn da was ist, eine wichtige Information, dann soll die auch für alle zugänglich sein und bleiben,
und deswegen ist das so ein Bereich in dem wir jetzt ein bisschen mehr noch tun und auch noch ein bisschen mehr tun werden. Einfach dafür zu sorgen, dass das Kraut so Pressefreiheit ein bisschen besser verteidigt wird, auch vor Gericht,
ähm wir wir haben da Lust auf ein paar mehr äh Klagen noch und werden da dann ein bisschen was für tun im Sommer.
Jetzt seid ihr ja nicht ähm also weiß nicht, wenn man wenn man jetzt so euch charakterisieren sollte, ist ein bisschen schwierig irgendwie so. Habe da irgendwie auch so eine komplett neue Kategorie von äh NGO aufgemacht, aber ihr habt ja auch,
viel ähm sagen wir mal, ja ihr agiert in einem Bereich,
die den ähm der Journalismus.
Betrifft, der den Journalismus betrifft. Ja, also dieses ganze,
Anfragen von Informationen des Staates und so weiter ähm ist ja eigentlich eine klassische, journalistische Tätigkeit, aber ihr seid ja in dem Sinne keine Journalisten.
Aber ihr versteht euch in gewisser Hinsicht auch als Dienstleister für den Journalismus kann man das äh so sagen oder ist das jetzt äh eine etwas unglückliche Formulierung.
Also ähm ich habe noch einen Rechtsstreit mit dem Innenministerium zur Frage, ob ich Journalist finde oder nicht. Deswegen muss ich hier sagen, ich bin Journalist ähm wie ich auch vor Gericht argumentiert habe.
Herr Nitsch, falls Sie zuhören, ich bleibe dabei. Ähm.
Okay.
Also ich habe auch einen Presseausweis. Es ist schon auch journalistische Arbeit, die wir machen und wir haben auch Journalistinnen im Team, aber natürlich ist frag den Staat,
irgendwie dazwischen. Also von von Anfang an waren Journalistinnen große Zielgruppe von dem Projekt und so die ursprüngliche ein bisschen optimistische Idee war,
nutzen einfach alle frag den Staat und dann können wir viel besser noch nachvollziehen wie Journalistin arbeiten und denn Ergebnisse werden viel transparenter und dann steht im Spiegel nicht mehr,
Dokumente, die uns vorliegen, sondern die Dokumente sind direkt veröffentlich,
Das war die Idee und das hat nur sehr begrenzt funktioniert, weil wir gelernt haben, dass grad so die etablierten Medien,
eigentlich wenig Interesse daran haben, ihre Recherchen dann im Nachgang irgendwie offen zu legen und es gibt natürlich eine eine Ausnahme eines Mediums, dass das sehr vorbildlich macht. Das ist Netzpolitik Punkt org,
Da sind im Prinzip alle Redakteurinnen sind bei Frag den Staat User und stellen Anfragen darüber ob Maka,
sehr gut nachvollziehen in der Regel, was was Infos sind und wie sie da rangekommen sind und kann sich davon was abgucken, wenn man das selbst auch machen will.
Und wir sind aber auch dazu übergegangen tatsächlich bei uns einer Journalistin anzustellen, weil wir gemerkt haben, einfach nur Infos irgendwie durch unsere Anfragen rauskriegen und die dann ein Medium geben, dass.
Nicht so, wie wir uns das vorstellen. Wir wir haben irgendwie einen anderen Anspruch an an Recherchen, wie sie funktionieren sollen,
und ähm wir haben jetzt zwei Journalistinnen bei uns im Team, Vera Delia Ottco und die das sehr konsequent machen und jede größere Recherche bei uns immer in Kooperation mit einem anderen Baby,
Also wir veröffentlichen eigentlich nichts selbst, nur sondern machen's immer mit anderen zusammen. Damit die dann so ein bisschen auf den Geschmack kommen, so zu arbeiten, vielleicht wie wir, damit wir natürlich auch mehr Reichweite bekommen.
Haben letztes Jahr vier Sendungen zusammen gemacht mit dem ZDF-Magazin Royal von Jan Böhmermann.
Ähm ich glaube die haben bisher mehr Reichweite, als es der frag den Startblock so hat. Ähm aber das sind total bereichernde Kooperationen. Ich glaube, für beide Seiten, weil wir da ganz viele Dokumente liefern können, die.
Journalistin sonst ganz häufig so nicht haben,
und wir dann aber auch nochmal anders über äh die Inhalte reden können und grad so ein Format wie das Magazin Royal, das bietet sich total an für die Arbeit äh die wir so machen, finde ich. Ähm deswegen machen wir da auch gerne noch ein bisschen mehr von in nächster Zeit.
Mhm. Was was habt ihr da ähm also kannst du mal ein paar Beispiele äh nennen für jetzt Veröffentlichungen, die ihr so in Zusammenarbeit mit äh anderen gemacht habt? Also muss nicht Hils Pimmermann sein, sondern.
Mit wem ihr noch so zusammengearbeitet habt.
Genau, also Böhmermann, also eine größere, die letztes Jahr auf jeden Fall mit mit der Sendung waren die Frontex Files, die wir im Februar letzten Jahres gemacht,
da ging's um die Zusammenarbeit von Kontext, also der EU-Grenzpolizei mit ähm Rüstungslobbyisten und wir konnten da über Anfragen ganz gut zeigen, dass die,
gelogen hatten dazu, lange gesagt hatten, sie haben sich nicht mit denen getroffen ähm und wir haben dann aber die Präsentation sogar irgendwie von Lok und Heckler und Koch und so veröffentlichen können äh und konnten da ganz gut zeigen, wie wie aufgerüstet wird. Aufrüstung jetzt ja auch wieder ein großes Thema,
diese Tage. Ähm Frontex haddit first. Ähm und wir ähm.
Lass mich mal kurz schauen selbst. Ähm wir haben jetzt gerade mit äh Korrektiv zusammen eine Recherche gemacht zu zur Versorgung ähm mit Schwangerschaftsabbrüchen.
Da lagen dann letztlich knapp 250 Anfragen an alle öffentlichen Krankenhäuser der Recherche zu Grunde über die man dann rausfinden konnte.
Wer nimmt denn eigentlich überhaupt noch Schwangerschaftsabbrüche vor? Das geht bundesweit zurück. Es sind immer weniger. Ähm wir haben.
Ähm im Oktober letzten Jahres zusammen mit RBB Kontraste und mit eine ähm Recherche gemacht zu Visavergaben und wir konnten zeigen wie das Auswärtige Amt,
ähm so eine Strategie fährt.
Dass sie ähm den Familiennachzug äh also den Nachzug von Angehörigen systematisch verzögert. Da hatten wir dann ein paar Dokumente bekommen, ähm das Fernsehen RBB Kontraste, die haben dann noch mal Betroffene interviewt dazu und so kommen dann die verschiedenen,
Stärken der einzelnen Medien zusammen und so kann man das dann in verschiedenen Medien ganz gut ausspiel.
Mhm. Und wie sind dann so eure Erfahrungen damit? Also geht geht die Strategie dann äh besser auf.
Also es ist ein langsamer Prozess. Ich glaube inzwischen haben mehr Medien Interesse daran, mit uns zusammenzuarbeiten. Das war.
Als ich angefangen habe mit der Arbeit auf jeden Fall nicht so, da waren wir irgendwie die die komischen,
werden Leute mit der Onlineplattform, das hat sich schon geändert jetzt, ähm aber es ist so, dass es mit manchen Medien immer noch einfach schwer ist. So, also es gibt so ein paar was so im investigativ Journalismusbereich, es gibt da so ein paar Medien, die sind so.
Sehr,
Testosteron halte ich drauf und da ist das dann immer superschwer. Also da da ist das das ist dann immer so eine Konkurrenz ähm und wir haben aber gar keinen Bock auf Konkurrenz in so einer Arbeit. Also wer hat jetzt den tolleren Scoop des,
haben wir gar kein Interesse dran, sondern wir wollen einfach irgendwie voneinander lernen ähm und das geht mit bestimmten Medien,
total gut, also mit Buzzfeed ist das immer super angenehm gewesen leider. Äh löst sich das jetzt ja auf ähm mit dem ZDF-Magazin Royal ist das auch wirklich immer sehr angenehm und so ein paar andere Medien ähm mit denen haben wir auch inzwischen ganz,
Arbeitsbeziehung.
Korrektiv und Netzpolitik org.
Also Netzpolitik Orkel, das ist äh Familie würde ich sagen. Ähm genau und korrektiv äh die gehören da auch noch mit dazu.
Ist in gewisser Hinsicht arbeitet dann schon sozusagen native, ja, weil nicht äh nicht weil man sich so gut kennt, sondern wie du ja schon erläutert hast, ne, weil sie ja quasi
äh den gesamten Rechercheprozess durch eure Plattformen schon von vornherein und dann eben auch dauerhaft transparent machen,
damit einfach ja auch schon so ein bisschen next Level Journalismus ne so weil,
Geheimniskrämerei äh wird eher generell immer als was was Gutes und zu bevorzugendes angesehen, aber es ist nicht unbedingt,
immer in allen Fällen so würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Wäre jetzt auch nicht schlechtreden.
Ich habe tatsächlich schon die Erfahrung gemacht, dass ich dachte, ich habe da irgendwie einen tollen Scoopliziert und dann,
wie wir es immer machen, die Dokumente mit dazu und dann,
Aber eine andere, ein anderes Medium, noch eine Follow-up-Geschichte gemacht mit Infos aus diesen Dokumenten, die mir gar nicht aufgefallen waren,
war diese follow up Geschichte toller als meine. Ähm das passiert so und das ist aber auch vollkommen okay,
wenn man halt die Dokumente mit dazu bringt, dann dann ist eben die Möglichkeit da, dass andere da noch was finden, was einem selbst nicht auffällt. Vielleicht auch rausfinden, dass man Fehler gemacht hat,
ähm da muss man dann halt offen dafür sein. Ähm man macht sich also durchaus auch,
bisschen angreifbar, ne, wenn alle nachprüfen können, hat er jetzt dieses Dokument richtig interpretiert oder nicht. Ähm,
da muss man dann schon bereit dafür sein, dass man äh dass man dann möglicherweise sich danach korrigiert.
Jetzt gab's ja Jüngst, wo du jetzt äh das ähm,
ZDF Magazin Royale heißt das jetzt überhaupt noch so oder ob's da nicht irgendeine Erinnerung? Ich weiß es nicht. Also hier Bömmermanns äh Show kennt ihr ja wahrscheinlich auch jeder äh,
Noch mal ein anderes Projekt gemacht, was aber jetzt glaube ich nicht in dem Sinne einen frag den Staat,
ist eigentlich mehr so ein privates Ding von dir gewesen, ne, der der Freiheitsfond. Sehe ich das richtig.
Genau, also ist eine ist eine äh kleine Gruppe, so eine Handvoll Leute, die das macht.
Ich bin der, der die der seine Fresse in die Kamera hält, wenn dann,
äh da Journalistin was zu wissen wollen, genau. Ähm ja, das das ist ein ein.
Projekt, das letztlich aus Anlass einer Sendung äh geschehen ist letztlich aus Anlass einer Kooperation zwischen fragt den Staat und dem Magazin Royal,
ähm in dem's ums Fahren ohne Fahrschein ging, also ähm um die Straftat tatsächlich, die man begeht, wenn man ohne Ticketbus oder Bahn fährt,
dazu führt, dass jedes Jahr ein paar tausend Leute im Knast landen letztlich. Ähm letztlich war sie zwei, drei, vier Mal ohne Ticket gefahren sind unter Freiheitsfond, der so ein Projekt äh der das sich noch mal ein bisschen genauer.
Kannst ja mal was zu sagen zu dem Hintergrund, weil ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, ob das jetzt schon jeder mal äh gehört hat. Ich ich kannte den
ähm den Fakt quasi so ein bisschen, glaube ich, wie das so vielen Leuten so geht, so hat man mal gehört, hat man mal Scheiße gefunden, sich dann wieder um andere Sachen gekümmert. Ähm,
es gibt einfach sehr viele Leute, die quasi ja keine Cola haben, ähm so ein Ticket zu kaufen, dann irgendwie erwischt werden, dann noch mal erwischt werden, dann nochmal erwischt werden und dann ist das halt,
eine Straftat so und keine Ordnungswidrigkeit und das ist es noch auf Basis eines alten zu Nazizeiten beschlossenen Gesetzes.
1935 wurde das äh eingeführt dieses Gesetz, genau. Ähm was dazu führt, dass Leute, die sich halt die
was weiß ich, zwei, drei Euro fürs Ticket nicht leisten können, sich natürlich das erhöhte Beförderungsentgelt 60 Euro auch nicht leisten können. Irgendwann eine Anzeige kassieren von der BVG oder einem anderen Verkehrsbetrieb und dann letztlich nach Vorurteilung,
viele hundert oder sogar 1tausend Euro zahlen müssen und wer sich die drei Euro am Anfang nicht leisten kann, der kann sich natürlich auf die 1000 Euro am Schluss nicht leisten ähm,
Und das führt dann wiederum dazu, dass,
ähm der Gesetzgeber vorgesehen hat, wer eine Geldstrafe nicht zahlt, muss in Haft. Das ist die Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe. Ähm was letztlich dazu führt, dass jedes Jahr ein paar tausend Leute,
Mit so einer Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe in den Knast kommen, weil sie die drei Euro am Anfang nicht zahlen konnten. Und das sind Leute, die.
In der Regel keinen Job haben, auch schon lange kein, häufig die keinen festen Wohnsitz haben, die vielleicht auf der Straße leben,
Leute mit äh psychischen Krankheiten häufig, also die vielleicht gar nicht in der Lage sind Post aufzumachen, wenn sie welche kriegen. Ähm Leute, die in in vielen Krisen sind, die schwer krank sind,
die müssen dann in den Knast ähm und,
Idee vom Freiheitsfond ist die Leute freizukaufen aus dem Knast. Was nämlich äh eine Möglichkeit ist in diesem System ist, dass man,
Leute befreit, indem man diese ursprüngliche Geldstrafe bezahlt. Also wenn ich mir jetzt die 1000 Euro Geldstrafe nicht leisten kann, dann muss ich dafür wahrscheinlich drei Monate in den Knast, kommt so ein bisschen auf den Einzelfall an, wie hoch das jeweils ist. Ähm.
Wenn aber diese 1000 Euro dann von der Person oder von jemand anderem bezahlt werden,
kann die Person in dem Moment den Knast wieder verlassen. Ähm und das führt dann natürlich dazu, dass man im Prinzip alle Menschen, die in Deutschland im Knast sind, wegen so einer Geldstrafe, wegen Fahnen ohne Fahrschein,
befreien kann, einfach indem man deren Geldstrafe zahlt. Und das ist die Idee vom Freiheitsfond. Letztlich in großer Form mit Geld drin, um Leute freizukaufen.
Aus dem Knast und das machen wir seit Anfang Dezember, sind also jetzt so knapp bei knapp drei Monaten ähm und haben, Stand heute, 293 Menschen bundesweit aus dem Knast.
Krass.
Habt ihr da irgendwie Rückmeldungen bekommen von den Leuten? Seid ihr da mit denen in irgendeiner Form mal in Kontakt getreten oder ist das äh etwas, wo ihr euch gar nicht weiter einmischt?
Also wir,
wir treten nicht von uns aus noch extra in Kontakt, weil das ja Leute sind häufig, die einfach traumatisiert sind. Wir wollen denen einfach den Raum lassen, aber natürlich gibt's Leute, die die uns danach dann noch kontaktieren. Also wir erfahren entweder von Ihnen oder von Ihren Angehörigen,
davon oder von Gefängnissen oder von Sozialarbeitern aus dem Umfeld von Gefängnissen davon und im Nachgang,
melden die sich dann bei uns in in manchen Fällen. Da zählen noch mal so bisschen ihre Geschichten.
Stell dir mal vor du kommst in den Knast ja und ausgerechnet die Justizbeamten geben dir die du kommst aus dem Gefängnis Freikarte.
Es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass dass sich ein paar Gefängnisse in Deutschland jetzt schon so auf den Freiheitsfond eingelassen haben,
quasi beim Check-In, ja, der Leute da die Formulare liegen vom Freiheitsfond.
Und dann die Leute deswegen reinkommen, dann die Justizbeamten sagen, schauen sie mal, gibt den Freiheitsfond, dann wird das ausgefüllt, dann schicken wir das an uns, fünf Minuten später überweisen wir und die Leute können wieder.
Natürlich ein verrücktes System, ja? Also der Staat, der Staat der dieses Problem verursacht, wendet sich jetzt an so eine an so ein paar Leute, die in Berlin sitzen.
Und sagt frei, kauft mal bitte unsere Leute hier aus dem Gefängnis frei.
Oh Mann ey.
Und und so einen ja so ein äh ein Bonbon, das wir immer wieder hören zur Entkriminalisierung und der,
Debatte ist von der CDU, die sagen immer, wenn wir das entkriminalisieren, dann ist das die Kapitulation des Rechtsstaats. Und,
Würde halt andersrum sagen, so was was ist denn mehr Kapitulation des Rechtsstaats, als wenn es jetzt Gefängnisse an zivilgesellschaftliche Organisation wenden, damit ihre Gefangenen freikaufen? Also da da merkt man doch, dass dieses System einfach kaputt ist,
Aber da sind wir jetzt angekommen tatsächlich. Wir lesen schnell die E-Mails. Wir überweisen schnell und wir haben jetzt,
Stand heute 326.000 Euro ausgegeben, ähm einfach um Leute zu befreien.
300 und wie viele Leute? 326tausend Euro. Wie viele Menschen kriegt man dafür frei?
Zweihundertdreiundneunzig, also so im Schnitt so knapp 1tausend bisher mehr als 1000 Euro pro Person ist das dann.
Tausendeinhundertundzwölf Euro und vor allem wie viel Geld habt ihr das auch mal ausgerechnet habt ihr denn dem Start erspart? Weil ich meine so einen Gefängnisaufenthalt kostet ja auch.
Ja, der kostet so im Schnitt 150 Euro pro Tag am Start und wir haben das wirklich auch tagesaktuell äh drei Komma vier sieben Millionen Euro. Haben wir damit gespart,
Ähm also der Faktor zehn so knapp. Wenn man das, wenn man das jetzt mal umsetzt in Hafttage, sind's 23195 Hafttage. Da sind so 63 Jahre Haft insgesamt, die wir da jetzt einfach.
Eliminiert haben.
Boah ist das krass. Es ist einfach nur nur heftig. Also von vorne bis hinten absolut irrsinnig, ne. Also ich meine Tausi in den Knast gehen, also ne.
Na ja, also wir haben gibt Leute, die,
wegen 200 Euro dann irgendwie einen Monat im Knast, ne. Die haben das Geld ganz einfach nicht und ich ich also wir hören so häufig auf
Twitter oder so, wo dann die Reaktionen ja so an die Leute sich doch ein Ticket kaufen. Und ich glaube, viele können sich gar nicht vorstellen, was für Situationen das sind. Also,
Leute, jetzt letzte Woche hatte ich einen, der äh jeden Tag zur Dialyse musste, ja? Der war schwer krank und der Arzt war halt woanders und dann ist er immer ohne Ticket gefahren, weil er's nicht sich nicht leisten konnte.
Am Schluss hatte der irgendwie zehn oder elf Mal ohne Ticket da eine Verurteilung und das war in München hat die Staatsanwaltschaft gesagt neun Monate.
Und der ist dann, ne, Dialysepatient, der braucht natürlich Behandlung, der musste dann in den Knast, weil er eine Straftat ist halt Straftat und der Staat, der bestraft das halt. Also das sind halt auch verrückte Fälle,
kannst du dir nicht ausdenken. Leute mit Kindern oder an die Kinder aus der Kita vom Jugendamt abgeholt werden, weil äh die Eltern jetzt in den Knast müssen, also ohne Ticket gefahren sind. Also es ist wirklich.
Wirklich verrückt.
Hast du dich auch eine Petition gestartet, um dieses Gesetz äh anzugehen?
Ich habe Camback, wie wie man das so macht. Da gehört dann noch eine Petition dazu. Ähm genau. Äh es es läuft grad noch eine dazu. Ähm und wir,
Wir richten das ans Bundesjustizministerium und das ist dafür zuständig und das auch auch relativ klar eigentlich, was passieren müsste. Man müsste halt diesen Straftatbestand abschaffen,
und wir haben jetzt viel Positives gehört aus dem Ministerium. Es wurde einmal gesagt, ja, wir prüfen das, wir prüfen das. Aber ist halt nichts konkret passiert und da müssen wir jetzt Druck machen, dass tatsächlich,
sich sicher auch was ändert, weil der Freiheitsfond natürlich nicht ewig Geld haben wird. Also wir wir machen das spendenfinanziert,
wir wir werden jetzt nicht ewig Geld haben dafür, da muss ich jetzt wirklich politisch was ändern, damit's den Freiheitsfond eben nicht mehr braucht. Also beim Freiheitsfond wäre ich wirklich, wirklich,
da wäre ich sehr froh drum äh der soll sich mal gern selbst abschaffen, den soll's nicht mehr.
Haben wir nicht gerade haben wir nicht grade so eine freiheitsorientierte Partei im Justizministerium in der Regierung. Mir war so.
Also äh für die Leute, die mir da befallen ist, auf jeden Fall jeden Tag Freedom-Day. Das kann ich mal sagen. Ähm das ist der echte Freedom Day, ja? Ähm ich würde auch sagen, das ist eigentlich müsste Herzensprojekt einer.
Freiheitlich demokratischen Partei sein.
Tschau. Gucken wir mal, was passiert. Finde ich auf jeden Fall eine super super geile Aktion, ganz ehrlich. Das äh,
äh schwer imponiert, vor allem die äh,
die Effizienz dieses Projektes äh lässt sich ja gar nicht hoch genug bewerten, ja, also so mit so einem unmittelbaren sofortigen
quantifizierbaren und auch qualifizierbaren Erfolg.
Ja, dass man einerseits halt Leute aus der Scheiße holt, aber andererseits auch noch dem Staat auch noch Geld spart, äh das ähm ja da will ich mal sehen, wie die Politik eigentlich dagegen äh argumentiert das Ding,
aufzuheben dieses Gesetz. Hast du da irgendwie schon mal Kontakt gehabt? Also ich meine, gibt's da irgendwie nicht irgendwelche Politiker, die sich da mal melden?
Hatten wir also auf sowohl auf Landes- als auch auf Bundesebene. Haben wir ähm das Bundesjustizministerium haben wir aber tatsächlich angeschrieben und noch nix. Noch niemanden erreicht. Ich ich glaube auch tatsächlich nicht, dass es.
Besonders viele Argumente dagegen gibt, aber die große Gefahr ist, dass das irgendwie ausgesessen wird. Also dass man einfach abwartet, bis bis sich das so ein bisschen legt und dann halt andere Themen wichtiger sind. Und das ist grad bei so einem Thema.
Riesen Problem, weil.
So wenig starke und öffentlich sichtbare Organisationen gibt, die sich da engagieren können.
Und deswegen die Gefahr besonders groß ist, dass das halt von der vom Radar wieder verschwindet und deswegen glaube ich muss auch viel jetzt bald passieren und nicht irgendwie am Ende der liegt.
Ja Mensch, Anne.
Schon was los bei euch? Kann man nicht anders sagen und äh habt ihr noch Expansions äh Wünsche? Wollt ihr euer Team noch weiter vergrößern oder wo geht's jetzt erst mal hin.
Also hier und da so ein bisschen. Wir hatten ein Brüsseler Büro gegründet letztes Jahr. Ich glaube das kann ein bisschen größer werden, aber ich glaube so für.
Für so eine Teamdynamik ist ist so fünfzehn, 16 Leute ganz gut eigentlich als Teamgröße. Ich glaube, was was jetzt so die Aufgabe ist von frag den Staat, ist.
Ein bisschen Schutzschild für andere zu werden. Also ich erinnere mich noch vor drei Jahren haben wir Frontex verklagt und haben verloren und Frontex wollte dann so 5undzwanzig000 Euro von uns und ich habe mir da tatsächlich angeschaut.
Macht man das jetzt eigentlich mit Privatinsolvenz und so, weil wir einfach das Geld nicht hatten und ich auf diesem Klage-Dings mit drauf stand und ich meine einfach anschauen musste. So und in der Situation sind wir jetzt zum Glück nicht mehr.
Sondern fragt den Staat ist jetzt groß genug, dass wir solche Risiken ohne.
Privatinsolvenzrisiko angehen können und ich glaube äh das ist jetzt so ein bisschen unsere Aufgabe, dass wir einfach Risiken eingehen und uns vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr verklagen lassen vom Staat, ein bisschen mehr Selbstklagen,
und so ein bisschen die Grenzen austesten. Ähm von dem, was denn eigentlich,
Informationsfreiheitsmäßig drin ist und was die die neue Regierung so mitgehen will oder was auch nicht,
und und das kostet ganz einfach Geld. Also solche Klagen sind halt einfach teuer und ähm ich glaube.
Noch so ein paar aggressivere Projekte, das steht an ähm.
Ja und sonst so ein paar größere Recherchen, paar größere Kampagnen ähm.
Und einfach noch noch ein bisschen mehr wirksamer werden, dass äh ist so das Ziel und so gegen die eigene gefühlte Ohnmacht kämpfen. Das geht dann immer so mit.
Hm. Brüsseler Büro heißt es, dass wir dann auch bald äh frag die Union äh kriegen oder was?
Na also äh die EU-Behörden sind ja schon drin beim praktisch Staat. Das machen wir schon,
Das ist tatsächlich mit integriert aber wir machen noch mehr genau also wir haben jetzt eine eine ähm zuständige da, Luisa die,
ähm eine Kampagne mit koordiniert, der heißt die zur Abschaffung von von Frontex ähm und wir machen ganz viel zu zu so Sicherheits- und Außenpolitik.
Und bereiten grad eine Klage vor gegen das EU-Parlament,
da kann ich noch nicht viel mehr zusagen aber das finde ich sehr spannend und da machen wir nochmal viel mehr und auf WU-Ebene klagen noch viel viel mehr äh ne viel viel weniger Leute tatsächlich das heißt da da kann man mit so ein paar gezielten äh.
Schnadelstichen glaube ich auch ein bisschen was ändern und das steht jetzt so an.
Die Situation in Bezug auf Informationsfreiheitskultur äh auf der EU-Ebene. Vergleich jetzt zu Deutschland zum Beispiel.
Also es es gibt auch ein Gesetz, das ist äh eine EU-Verordnung, zehn neunundvierzig aus zweitausendeins so ein schöner EU-Name. Ähm damit hat man das Recht auf auf Dokumente von EU-Behörden.
Nutzen auch Leute, aber,
vergleichsweise wenig. Das ist so ein bisschen eher die die Brüsseler Bubble, die das nutzt. Also die Leute, die sich dann halt mit den Institutionen auskennen und das ist natürlich ein sehr,
sehr geschlossener Kreis und darüber hinaus wird das sehr wenig genutzt. Also es gibt jedes Jahr, ich glaube,
an EU-Institutionen 8000 Anfragen. Wenn man sich mal überlegt irgendwie, die EU hat 400 Millionen Einwohner, die da Anfragen stellen könnten, ist das natürlich wahnsinnig wenig.
Ähm das ist natürlich einfach so ein Komplexitäts-EU-Ding. Das ist aber,
einfach glaube ich, dass dass ganz viele nicht wissen, dass es diese Möglichkeiten gibt und deswegen müssen wir das noch ein bisschen stärker machen, aber EU-Sachen sind natürlich immer.
Super schwierig zu erklären. Also die die Herausforderung kennt ihr ja auch.
Ja, na klar.
Deswegen müssen wir da halt auch schauen wie wir da irgendwie Kampagnen machen können, um Leute dafür zu begeistern. Das ist glaube ich mit mit Frontex so ein ganz guter Anfang, weil man da inzwischen zumindest glaube ich,
gewisses Bild davon hat, ah ja, das sind die, die irgendwie Leute zurückschicken. Ähm und das müssen wir auch versuchen in Bezug auf ein paar andere Institutionen so hinzukriegen, so läuft.
Ja Mensch, Arne, super. Nino, hast du noch was?
Ich bin immer noch ganz baff mit den ganzen befreiten Leuten.
Deswegen äh da fällt mir jetzt gar nichts mehr zu ein. Muss ich ehrlich sagen. Das ist so eine so eine krasse Nummer.
Wenn man sich überlegt, wie was für ein irren Erfolg die in so einer kurzen Zeit hatte, ne, was ist das jetzt? Etwas über ein Jahr maximal oder?
Freiheitsfonds drei Monate.
Nö, das ging noch weniger drei Monate, ja.
Hör mir auf.
Muss ja auch sagen, ich glaube, das ist auch kein Geheimnis. Das ging ja, weil wir es nicht geschafft haben, schnell genug einen einen Verein zu gründen. Das ging ja alles über mein Privatkonto, ne.
Und 3326tausend Euro ausgeben innerhalb von drei Monaten. Also ich weiß ja nicht, wie es bei euch ist, aber ich habe das vorher noch nicht gemacht.
Ich habe hier, ich habe ich habe jeglichen Bezug zu Geld verloren, kann ich euch sagen. Also.
Zuerst seine BVG Jahreskarte gekauft.
Ich verstehe da nichts mehr von. Ich denke nur noch an Tausenderschritten, einfach weil das.
Also tausend Euro bedeutet eine Person frei kaufen können. Das ist so jetzt mein neuer Maßstab. Ich hoffe, dass ich irgendwann wieder wieder einen normalen Kontostand habe, damit das sich wieder einrenken kann. Aber.
Also ihr habt jetzt einen Verein gegründet dafür oder wie?
Ja also wir sind jetzt dabei einen Verein zu gründen, was es so ein bisschen schwierig macht.
Ist, dass wir den natürlich gern gemeinnützig haben wollen. Das wäre dann das Schöne. Dann könnte man halt spenden und dann würde der Staat das noch zusätzlich subventionieren, dass man dem den Freiheitsfond unterstützt. So,
und Leute freikauft, ähm dann müssen wir noch die richtigen Formulierungen finden, damit das Finanzamt das auch gut findet. Bisher haben die das nämlich abgelehnt. Das ist gemeinnützig.
Das kann überhaupt nicht gemeinnützig sein Leute aus dem Knast rauszukriegen.
Was ich da so manchmal so anschaut, was problemlos, gemeinnützig ist in diesem Land, ähm na ja, aber das Thema hatten wir ja auch schon öfter. Das Gemeinnützigkeit, glaube ich, generell äh in unserer Gesellschaft nochmal überdacht und äh der,
modernen Realität angepasst gehört. Alright, Arne.
Wenn du jetzt nicht noch irgendetwas äh Wichtiges uns und uns allen äh noch mitgeben willst, würde ich sagen, machen wir den Sack langsam mal zu. Hast du noch was?
So, ist auch gut. Habe ich genug gequatscht oder.
Na ja, wir hören ja immer gerne zu.
Wer äh jetzt müsste noch ein Lied singen.
Karriere hat er jetzt nicht äh auch noch mit im Bord, oder.
Es fehlen ja jetzt irgendwie zwei Kongresse mit Live-Musikauftritten aus dem Hause äh frag den Staat. Hm da dürfen wir ja wohl durchaus was erwarten, oder?
Na ja, aber wir haben auch neulich diesen Film, äh dieses Musikvideo hatten wir das nicht sogar schon äh hier irgendwo hinten dran. Na ja, haben wir doch alle.
Ja
Ne, aber aber das wollen wir natürlich, aber ich will natürlich der Entscheidung des der Content-Gruppe nicht vorweggreifen, aber sollte fragt den Staat wieder mal zu einem Live-Kongress eingeladen, angenommen werden. Dann gibt's wieder Live-Musik auf jeden.
Das sagt der eine jedes Jahr, weil er weiß, dass ich im Content-Team bin,
immer das Gespräch beginnt immer so Anne, also jetzt echt also irgendwann müssen wir euch mal nicht im Programm haben,
Und dann kommt so, ja nee, ist okay. Wir haben ja nur das das, das, das, das gemacht. Kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das nicht reicht, ja? So.
Erpresser hier, Erpresser.
Dann berichten wir über den Freiheitsfond halt woanders. Ist ja jetzt nicht so als.
Fast schon der Kongress. Arne, vielen Dank.
So, wir zeigen nochmal die ganzen Spendenadressen und so haben wir in den in den Shownotes, ne?
Genau.
Und äh ja was was bleibt anderes als äh den Hut zu ziehen und die Geldbörse, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.
So sieht's aus. Alles klar, das war's für heute. Wir sagen tschüss, bis bald.
Danke Arne.
Dankeschön.